[Music]
a new zealand woman who was angry with
her husband for ghosting her
during a boys trip
made a dark humor tick tock revealing
that he was actually dead the whole time
that's new zealand humor
humor basically
this woman her husband went out with the
boys for like a little trip
she was texting him wondering why he
wasn't responding and he died on the
trip and he was dead that's why he
wasn't responding but her way of uh
dealing with it she just made a tick
tock
kind of like a you know and i really
love this type of uh i like her though i
like people that can deal with crazy
[ __ ] like that and this is her uh
comedy's the best way to cope oh that's
as big as this [ __ ] goes is it like that
was it the weekend at bernie's or no
when they have the dead guy and they
party with them and [ __ ] i wish it was
that funny
oh it's a gangnam style
[Music]
what happened he was dead he was dead
whoa
holy [ __ ] what a good song
i know
what a song to use classic but uh yeah
so apparently the dude
was uh he was looking at his phone when
he was like trying to walk down like
some kind of embankment because she was
texting him so she killed him well he
was watching a video apparently and then
uh he didn't realize that it was super
straight down this guy falls off dies on
impact
holy [ __ ] what do we always say
people on our phone dude stop walking
and and watching videos yeah because
you'll die on impact yeah what do you
think he was watching yeah only testing
to drive if you're good at it it was
probably so that was my always watching
did i saw i saw a chick well first of
all she was driving slow as [ __ ] and i
was like of course she's probably on her
phone and then i pull up on the side yes
she is on her phone scrolling oh by the
way she also has a baby in the car oh
she
did she's talented
i was at the stop light right and i was
on my phone and then i looked over and
there was a cop right there right and
thank god he wasn't looking at me
because he was looking at the lady who
was on her phone and he went ha ha ha
and she went
and then she went
and i was like that's right
that's right
you're like good all these people on
their phones is annoying yeah
like i see i should see i'll be on my
phone with couples oh [ __ ] i look over
the cops on their phone
yeah for real that's good they're always
on their phone everyone's on their phone
constantly yeah really sad but uh i hope
when i die that
you know people think of me this way
make funny [ __ ] out of it i hope
you have to die in hilarious way i think
i have a banner that says finally luck
caught up to you
you escaped it too many times you're a
lucky son of a [ __ ] or it's like now
you're in the story yeah yeah i hope
people get [ __ ] lit at my funeral if
you guys don't die of natural causes
and it has to be like adventure related
like this like how would you it has to
be adventure related yeah like it has to
like this like he's on vacation a boys
trip right to wherever like hike or boat
or whatever like what what would be the
way it could be something not that like
we're people here and like
how did you die from that
like i got swallowed by a whale wow
there you go
that's badass though you go whale watch
it and then it's like
best case now i like saved somebody else
and then got swallowed honorable and
you're jonah in the whale that means
nina's gonna [ __ ] bust one more to
you to your thoughts he was such a good
man oh he pushed someone and then got
eaten by a big mammal chicks do that
it's not as cool if you were just saving
a dolphin or something that's kind of
weird girls get so horny i get swallowed
by a dolphin
that's why they fantasize about firemen
they love heroes they just love heroes
yeah they love them that's what disney
taught me i would do it so it's like
go-karting and everyone's like how the
[ __ ] and then like and then look it up
like i guess 55 people died go-karting
every year
really
it would be like the tiny number in the
stack that people really died yeah they
do i think it's mostly chicks because of
their [ __ ] hair right that's the
story i always hear the area gets caught
in the in the rotating parts of behind
them that is literally the worst way to
die really [ __ ] bad because you go
you're like we have a good day go
curtain
you have so much fun you're so hyped to
go
it's like steve what if you died in a
laser tag accident dude i don't know how
because i'd be i'm wrecking all these
little mexican kids
or you can't [ __ ]
hit in the eye and then you get a
seizure you died from exhaustion just
smoking all those kids dude where i was
in van nuys it was only me and a bunch
of mexican kids and i was smoking those
you were like remember the animal food
well no what i do is what i do is i i
take my phone out i put the flashlight
on and then i [ __ ]
can't do [ __ ]
they do that like airsoft crazy oh
people take their phone out for airsoft
no they have like flashlights and [ __ ]
oh and they flash your eyes you're like
what the [ __ ] and you get [ __ ] cheaters
yeah crazy i don't know if that's street
legal i like acting like i take laser
tag way too seriously when i'm there too
like i'm like
it's [ __ ] golden you're you're the
first guy out the door at the end to
look at the screen
[ __ ] yeah
i'm first in first stop yeah first and
first now just like the seals check it
out let's check this out
the batteries in the right way check it
and i'm gonna go and i'm the guy i'm
like i'm like are you sure are you sure
this is are you sure this is good are
you sure this is good to the guy he's
like yeah it's fine that's fine
would you calibrate this this laser what
are you doing i guess very few ways to
die are as cool as if you were like
saving somebody yeah that's probably
that's something that's probably best
i wanna i wanna die selfishly swallowed
by what's so crazy what do you mean by
that how do you mean huh what would be a
selfish way to die nah i mean like you
deserved it you son of a [ __ ] you were
trying to [ __ ] do something dumb
like
i take a canoe over a niagara falls like
that kind of [ __ ] oh that's that's
pretty dope like the person that went
over a bucket on the high ground like
they were in a barrel yeah didn't
multiple people do that but isn't that a
story where like nick dunn hears this
he's like he's a [ __ ] idiot
no i want to be like at a buffet
fighting with other you know chinese
grandmas for the crab and somehow my
greedy ass tries to take all the crab
and then i slip and fall the crabs legs
just fall on my face and kill me yeah
yeah
and it's like you died being a greedy
son of a [ __ ] i see
the man who died with the crab legs
stuck on his face your tombstone's gonna
have like a stone crab on top of it you
died from the green facial crab stab i
think i think joe's like playing with
crocodiles or something yeah and he gets
eaten that's that's what happens with
joe
he's like messing with some animal like
with some exotic animal that he has as a
pet exotic joe yeah exotic joe dude
my worst nightmare
my worst nightmare for dying and it
still holds is that i really don't want
that [ __ ] to end up on like live leak or
like i don't want it to be on social
media and have a bunch of guys
commenting going man i would have done
this that's gonna be me dude that's
gonna be the comments if that was me i
would have dodged to the left actually
like he's a [ __ ] idiot it's because
of [ __ ] and it's because we've all been
on the other side of that [ __ ] and we
know how like small we make that
person's death we're like man a dude
like me i would have done just make sure
that it gets a jk news it could be on
lively just not jk news
by the time it gets to us all of us be
like man what a [ __ ] i would have done
this
remember that one shake that you know
how people like sometimes like to stay
behind where uh where the airplanes take
off oh yeah yeah and then like the the
[ __ ] thrusters are like pushing
people back and stuff yeah yeah yeah and
then one one lady like was trying to
hold the barricade and the thing [ __ ]
flew off and she flew and hit her head
she just died
it's like dang you just died by wanting
to watch the back thrusters of an
airplane take off you know what's scary
i went uh indoor skydiving with tycoons
i thought it would be cute as [ __ ] to
see even those little [ __ ] little
squirrel suit thing
and then there's a guy on the control
thing he like adjusts the air
uh based off of the person's weight
right right so that looks like you're
like like floating and then my like it
just looks like like a cheese grater
and then with like a giant fan and what
i was scared of is you're supposed to
take turns but i'm i was scared that
like when i go and then after i'm done
they kept the fan on and then it brings
tiger the tiger just [ __ ] flies and
then when they fly i think he goes oh
[ __ ] and turns the fan down then he
comes
and he turns into a blender because the
fan because there's a lot of dust going
on you know it's the instructor in there
and
looking at the guy in the control room
and they gotta have like a lot of like
communication and it's that guy's first
job out of high school yeah and he's
high yeah i know that's kind of scary i
like oh [ __ ] before he does something
that's a good that's always feels good
that is scary because there was a recent
thing i didn't want to cover it because
the dude was so young but there was a 14
year old kid who died on a roller
coaster recently
someone sent the video uh icon
it's just like a what's icon it's like i
don't know it's like one of those ones
it just like drops it just drops like a
carnival ride thing it's like death drop
kind of thing what it just it just
well it's like free fall it's like it's
like uh yeah it's like tower of terror
but like exterior so then it went down
and then i guess the force
like
literally pulled them out of his shirt
because this guy was this kid was way
too heavy like he's too fat he was way
over the weight limit so what happens
the reason why they got these like
weight limits is because it's not
because oh you're so heavy you're gonna
fly out it's also because
the seats and the locking mechanisms
can't fully close when you're there then
why do they let us fat ass on why do you
what hey that's the best question why do
you think what do you think is going to
come with you oh is that are you going
to fat shame me you're going to fashion
me but let me on is it that's the only
reason i could possibly think of why
they would still be like because they
don't want to make it i don't want to
tell them because it's probably some
like high school kid or some young kid
that's like operating this because 14
years only weighs 380 something pounds
380. it's 300 something i don't know if
it's 800. that's not fat shaming that's
being descriptive and safe it's 300
something but yeah it's like that's even
is that possible i think that's when
like not wanting to fat shame meets
safety protocol
and there's your result it's like
because you there's a video of it and
obviously we can't show it but yeah the
video
uh the the seat doesn't open like it
wasn't a failure in the mechanism but
it's designed to not be able to hold a
guy that big like so because the the the
thing that goes like that it just went
like that well yeah it doesn't it's like
it's not as like like if you were to
close this thing it just wouldn't be as
low so that will probably look like a
neck pillow
so he fell out or he got like stretched
out he fell out he just fell out of it
at the top right well because if you
think of a ride that's designed to like
have a downward force and then stop yeah
so like if you're if you're over the
weight limit you're the force of you
is just gonna continue over and yeah he
just spilled out of the mechanism like
that's so sad bro and now his worst
nightmares realize he's he's a jk's
article
yeah so that's that's the thing with
like you got a person that's an operator
you know it's not only the safety first
bro not [ __ ] [ __ ] nice to me like
if if you really think i'm not safe for
this ride like don't let me get on this
here's what ai is about right you need a
robot there that has no emotion and then
everybody who walks by they're just
walking on like a weight scale yeah
it's like
no too fat
yeah because they would say garbage in
garbage out right they would say that
the programmers are [ __ ] you know
what i mean then buyers
yeah yeah so then it it's you know a lot
of people are starting to wonder like do
they need weight scales at amusement
parks i want to go to six flags and be
like you're too asian for this one
ninja remember ninja do they still got
ninja over there oh yeah that was
awesome yeah that they do but i we're
too asian to ride ninja racing for this
ride sir so sorry you're too authentic
to ride a fake asian [ __ ] roller
coaster i don't make the rules sir
you're gonna ruin it for all the whites
that's what they're gonna say yeah we
got a lot of nice white families back
there we're waiting to go on this ride
so yeah you gotta go somewhere else see
a tatsu or something
do
[Music]